ladies and gentlemen we know them from
the stormlight archive books
we got rock we got taft we got
zigzil we got the funny one it's [ __ ]
bridge four give it give it up give it
up for bridge four
give it up for bridge whoa now they're
over there whoa
that was so dumb but i don't care
because today we're doing the
bridge for book tag bridge for book tag
i was tagged by chase at fantasy talk
who has
a terrific channel you should absolutely
go watch his channel
bunny content all sorts of variety just
go watch his channel because it's
it's it's [ __ ] great the tagger was
originated by
megan's reading revelations i think so i
think that's
where it originated and if so thank you
these are fun questions
and um first question and all of these
questions
go with the names of the the characters
in bridge four so first question name a
book where food is a big theme
or it is influenced by food
how can i not charlie in the chocolate
factory and charlie in the great glass
elevator frankly if i may be so bold
charlie in the great glass elevator
is the superior book i don't mean to be
controversial here just because it
wasn't turned into a movie
doesn't mean it's a lesser book just as
great as the original if not more so
come on chocolate charlie and the
chocolate factory give me a [ __ ]
break
let's go sigzel what is a book that
features a prominent storyteller
i'm going with a classic hamlet
prominent storyteller the [ __ ]
players who
strut their way on the stage what
is that even from hamlet no that's from
macbeth the players in hamlet
i'm talking about you charlton heston in
kenneth branagh's
1994 95-96 classic
hamlet adaptation i'm talking to you you
are
a storyteller within this this whole
story and the players basically
are pivotal in the story because they
get claudius to react to
seeing the in the play the way he killed
his brother and
it's all [ __ ] fantastic renarin name
a book
renarin is the light eyes member of
bridge
will forgive him for that name a book
that has a character that has to
overcome a physical or mental challenge
i'm going to say the shining because
jack
has to overcome his alcoholism
huge part of that book which is totally
discarded in the movie
not totally but you know it's very very
minor in the movie whereas it's
humongous in the book i was very
grateful that it went so
in depth so the shining is great i think
a great example
i think another great example is is is
charlie's grandpa
and charlene the chocolate factory when
he just overcomes
his ill whatever illness he had he just
jumps out of bed and suddenly he's like
hey
kid come on let's give me that [ __ ]
golden ticket we're going to the [ __ ]
chocolate factory
okay grandpa oh you're totally you're
just faking your [ __ ] illness this
whole time you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i don't want to get into that you know
what good on him good on him for
overcoming
his his illness and in the instant he
found out that there was [ __ ]
chocolate to go
eat this book disappoints me more than i
think about it number four lopin
name a character that is not afraid to
try new
things ishmael in moby dick ishmael he
he's able to try new things you know at
first
in moby dick he's a bit careful around
queequeg
a bit racist let's be real here then
they end up
you know sleeping in a bed together you
know just just bros
five feet apart because they're not good
later in the book ishmael starts to
accept and they become brothers they're
bonded ishmael always trying new things
good on them
number five moash name a character that
is morally gray
do i even have to talk about moash i
mean
all right i'll name a character who's
morally gray i'm going to go with
hal 9000 in 2001 a space odyssey
in the rest of the space odyssey series
he's very
right in the sense of his programming
however morally gray in that the sense
that he doesn't really have a strong
sense of morality because he's just okay
killing right he's okay with that he's
not okay with telling lies he has issues
with that
you know he's a complicated soul god i
can't believe i i'm comparing moash to
hal 9000
hal does not deserve that teft name a
character whose past haunts them
i'm still in the process of reading this
book and i am loving it so far but
this just came to mind that the
character will's dad
in something wicked this way comes i
think his name is charles holloway a
really
interesting character he's coming to
term the way he's depicted
as coming to terms with his mortality
with becoming
older and feeling like life has you know
passed him by which i think is a feeling
that a lot of people feel at all all
points in their life even if you're
young you know you can have that feeling
and he's a character who has regrets
about not about doing something horrible
but about not doing
enough you know he's a really compelling
character i'm really happy to be reading
about him still name a chara name a
non-human companion character that
constantly offers advice
[ __ ] i should have gone with hal 9000
for this answer
i'm gonna i'm gonna say moby [ __ ]
dick that's what i'm gonna say
i'm going to say that moby dick is a
companion character
and they're going to listen to my essay
while i rant about this for five minutes
moby dick is the amalgamation to the
physical plane of reality
so that's how is a companion character
and moby dick
offers advice because he appears in a
counterpoint
to captain ahab's character so moby dick
is basically
captain ahab's sill
kaladin name a character from a book
that is more than
they appear i don't know if this is a
great one to compare to caledon but i'm
going to go with judge holden from blood
meridian
judge holden looks like a big fat egg he
looks like a baby
he's comp his face is compared to that
of like a dolphin like baby face dolphin
totally hairless gigantic seven foot
tall
huge fat weird ass egg looking man you
think
this person would be kind of like easy
to make fun of but when you actually
think about it and when you read about
this character he is the most horrifying
individual i could ever possibly imagine
ever so no he is not what he seems he
seems like a big [ __ ] creep
and he is actually literally satan not
maybe not literally but
he's worse than satan this has been a
really weird
book tag and i i think most of the books
i mentioned aren't even fantasy
that was the bridge for book tag once
again chase from fantasy talk
tagged me in this go subscribe to his
channel
and then after you do that subscribe to
my channel because we're all one big
family we're all just a big booktube
family bridge four
let's let's go be let be cool
oh there they are again oh my god oh god
all right i don't think they're gonna
come back anymore